je suis j'ai pas besoin de le dire très
heureux qu'on se retrouve si nombreux
déjà ce soir parce que tous ceux qui ont
dû traverser la France pour venir à
Guidel c'est rare que la séance du
vendredi soir s'ouvre devant autant de
autant de
monde j'ai plusieurs chose à vous dire
la première c'est que le covid est de
tour il y a plusieurs des nôtres qui ont
été en situation de le de le
rencontrer et donc je vous encourage à
être prudent à limiter les
effusions qui pourtant vous sont
habituels
diurnes et vespéral j'ai pas dit
nocturne donc je suis très content qu'on
soit là
euh pour
euh réfléchir comme nous le faisons
confronter nos regards sur une situation
dont je vais dire un mot dans une minute
euh c'est un moment
particulièrement pas comment on peut
dire
décisif de des temps que nous vivons et
de ce que nous allons traverser et de ce
que nous avons à traverser
euh le
le il y a longtemps que les continents
dérivent à la surface de la
planète et cette fois-ci il dérive aussi
en politique à la surface de la
planète le le les très grands mouvements
géopolitiques qui sont lancés
géopolitiques et si
j'osis je dirais géosociologique c'est
ce qui se passe dans la profondeur des
peuples qui paraissait stabilisé depuis
des décennies depuis la guerre et qui
aujourd'hui est complètement
bouleversé tout ce qui se passe là
intéresse chacun d'entre nous et si l'on
croit que on va pouvoir traverser les
temps qui viennent
sans que nous nous reposions les
questions fondamentales on se trompe
euh les questions fondamentales qui
tiennent à
notre simplement à notre place dans
l'humanité et à la responsabilité que
nous avons nous humains nous occidentaux
nous européens nous Français euh c'est
jamais nous n'avons été placés devant
des responsabilités comme celle-là
depuis très longtemps euh tout ce qui
était
stable connaît aujourd'hui des
bouleversement
profond alors il y a les bouleversements
qu'on voit évidemment qu'on ressent le
les changement climatique le changement
climatique et les changements que qui
sont induits par le changement
climatique dans dans tous les aspects de
la vie on a le ministre de l'agriculture
et la ministre de la biodiversité donc
c'est dire à quel point nous sommes
frappés par cela on a le ministre de
l'outreem et et la question de l'outrem
elle est absolument centrale nous nous
n'allons pas pouvoir passer les années
qui viennent sans que cette question là
trouve des réponses
nouvelles et puis on a le ministre du
numérique et Dieu sait que dans les
changements que nous
évoquons la question du numérique est
une
question qui est qui est un une onde de
choc
pour la totalité de notre organisation
de société et donc on a beaucoup de
chance d'avoir ces responsabilités on a
beaucoup de chance d'être ensemble pour
les pour les
vivre et quand je dis être ensemble pour
les vivre ceux qui ne nous connaîtrai
pas ou ceux qui nous suivent sur
Internet cette famille politique n'est
pas tout à fait une famille politique
comme les autres secours politique n'est
pas tout à fait un courant politique
comme les autres pour deux
raisons la première qui est très
importante pour nous c'est que avec le
temps dans la traversé des déserts et
Dieu sait que nous avons connu des
traversées du
désert dans la traversée du désert
quelque chose s soudé en nous c'est
cimenté en nous qui fait que nous vivons
et c'est pour un responsable politique
expérimenté c'est très original et très
heureux nous vivons nous une solidarité
sans aucune faille c'est rare les
mouvements
politiques puissant qui ont un groupe
puissant à l'Assemblée nationale une
influence sur la vie politique et qui
vivent une solidarité sans faille pour
ma part j'en connais pas
beaucoup et même dans histoire j'en
connais pas beaucoup et nous nous avons
cette chance là je disais ça à des
journalistes tout à l'heure c'est
infiniment précieux et bien sûr vous
savez pourquoi c'est étroitement lié euh
au caractère escarpé des chemins que
nous avons parcourus euh
de comment comment dit La
Fontaine un chemin et de tous les côtés
au soleil exposés de tous les côtés aux
orages exposés aussi ça nous a permis
de de créer quelque chose qui est
euh infiniment précieux parce que
infiniment
rare donc c'est le premier point c'est
une famille politique dont
l'organisation est fondée sur une
solidarité sans
faille et deuxièmement c'est une famille
politique c'est un courant politique qui
porte un message qui n'a pas changé
depuis des décennies et qui aujourd'hui
se trouve exactement à
l'épicentre de tous les problèmes qui se
posent dans le
monde pourquoi parce que nous
revendiicons d'avoir une philosophie
politique et cette philosophie politique
qui se résume en un mot souvent galvodé
mais qui mérite d'être rappelé nous
sommes des humanistes dans la vie
politique française nous sommes des
humanistes dans la vie politique
européenne c'est-à-dire que nous
considérons que le le le but de l'action
politique c'est de créer une société
dans
laquelle l'humanité qu'il y a en chacun
d'entre nous
s'épanouira que chacun
soit plus créatif euh plus
sensible et plus
conscient je veux je veux vous rappeler
cette phrase de que je répète tout le
temps donc vous serez pas
surpris cette phrase du du grand
philosophe politique Marc Sanier qui
était à la qui était à la fondation il y
a 100 ans de cette famille politique il
dit la démocratie et l'organisation
sociale qui porte à son plus haut la
conscience et la responsabilité de
chacun la conscience et la
responsabilité de
chacun et ça donne une vision
complètement différente de ce qui se
passe comme vous savez j'ai prononcé le
mot de démocratie dans tous les partis
politiques que j'ai eu la chance de
diriger dans la longue chaîne de de
fidélité et de succession il y a eu des
formes politiques différentes toujours
il y a eu le mot démocratie dans le
titre toujours
euh et donc euh ça n'est pas pour rien
c'est parce que nous avons une idée
de de l'engagement politique qui
précisément répond euh au problème du
temps de comme vous savez la démocratie
est aujourd'hui
contestée
fondamentalement alors qu'on croyait il
il y a encore 15 ans 20 ans qu'elle
avait triomphé que c'était fait que
c'était comme disait le grand le grand
politiste que c'était la fin de
l'histoire avec la chute du mur de
Berlin nous et nous voyons aujourd'hui à
quel point la démocratie
est dans sa son existence même ou dans
ces dans les épisodes qu'elle traverse
fragiliser à un point qui n'a jamais été
le cas au point qu'elle est aujourd'hui
la démocratie minoritaire dans le
monde les pays les continents les
organisations
politiques démocratiques sont
minoritaires dans le monde il suffit de
voir ce qui se passe en Chine et ce qui
va se passer en
Chine la Chine va perdre dans les 30 ans
qui
viennent
l'équivalent de la totalité de la
population
européenne 500 millions d'habitants ou
450 millions d'habitants de
moins parce que la politique qui a été
suivie la politique de l'enfant unique
fait
que
inéluctablement et les questions
démographiques sont des questions sans
suspense
qui est né est né qui n'est pas né ne
naîtra
pas il y a pas de d'inconnu ou
d'incertitude si on peut faire mourir
beaucoup plus de gens encore mais enfin
ceux qui sont pas nés vous les
retrouverez pas et ça touche tous les
problèmes la pyramide des âes touche
tous les problèmes
singulièrement Alfred si disait ça très
bien singulièrement le la vitalité d'un
PE peuple sa créativité sa capacité à
entreprendre sa volonté de regarder
l'avenir avec optimisme ou pessimisme
tout ça est est intimement lié la Chine
va vivre ça au contraire
l'Inde va avoir une progression de sa
population l'Inde qui est elle-même pr
prise
dans dans des crispations incroyable
entre religion entre identité et
religion
euh
l'Afrique va connaître une explosion de
sa
population et c'est à côté de chez nous
hein et si vous ajoutez la crise
climatique par-dessus tout ça
mais la crise économique la crise
politique le fait que le que les les
assauts des
intégrismes sont en train de travailler
profondément ces peuples en
difficulté tout cela on va vivre et ceux
qui croiraient ou qui prétendrai
que il y aura une cloison étanche entre
les événements du monde et notre vie
nationale cela sont des enfants
comprennent pas ce qui va se
passer et c'est pourquoi les questions
d'immigration recevra ce soir à
yamsuro d'immigration et
d'asile dont elle a fait ement de sa vie
ces questions sont évidemment centrales
aussi importantes que les questions qui
touch au climat aussi importante que les
questions qui touchent à
l'énergie et tout cela nous l'affrontons
nous
français avec un modèle unique et plus
fragile que les
autres je veux je veux insister sur ce
point le l'organisation
que notre pays a choisi qui est une
organisation fondée sur la la solidarité
maximale la prise en charge par la
communauté de tous les investissements
de d'éducation de la maternelle au
collège de
France de tous les investissements de
santé la garantie des retraites
universelles
et ce qui est assurance
chômage tout ce qui est de l'ordre de la
des équipements publics tout cela en
France et c'est le seul pays au
monde qui a fait ça repose uniquement
sur cette règle que j'ai simplifié en
l'appelant la règle du tous pour un
encore faut-il qu'il y ait des tous que
le
nombre de ceux qui vont contribuer à la
solidarité soit en proportion avec le
nombre de ceux qui vont bénéficier de la
solidarité et si vous regardez rien
qu'une seconde les rapports numériques
entre les deux alors vous avez une idée
des problèmes que nous allons rencontrer
et dans ce temps-là crise climatique
crise géopolitique crise passion
religieuse
intégrisme déstabilisation des société
regardez la société
américaine le
le ne serait que
politiquement il y a un sondage hier qui
donne Trump 10 points devant
Biden 10 points devant Biden et c'est
comme une course poursuite entre les
poursuites d'un côté le et la la
fanatisation d'une partie de l'opinion
américaine plus la guerre chez
nous la guerre en
Ukraine le ha carabach aujourd'hui dont
personne ne parleou pas
beaucoup le surgissement de la vague de
l'inflation et comme vous savez j'ai
souvent répété que ceux qui croient que
les vagues d'inflation s'arrêtent du
jour au lendemain ont pas beaucoup
regardé l'histoire des grands mouvements
monétaire sur ces sujetsl on va
l'affronter et il n'y a qu'une seule
réponse possible comme tu le disais pour
moi il y a peut-être des des gens qui
vont raconter
que on peut s'en tirer tout seul c'est
ce que disait madame mélonie
elle s'est fait élire en
disant on va régler tout seul la
question de l'immigration que l'Europe
reste chez elle et puis moins d'un an
après
on voit on voit la la situation et
donc pour nous cette question est vitale
et il se trouve que par
chance pour la première fois depuis très
très très longtemps on va avoir des
élections européennes qui nous placeront
en
situation
exceptionnelle je parle de nous et de
nos amis de la majorité en situation
exceptionnelle pour pourquoi parce que
nous serons les seuls dans le champ
politique à défendre cette
thèse autrefois il y avait concurrence
entre les différentes visions de
l'Europe aujourd'hui il me semble qu'il
y a même plus concurrence sur ce
sujet-là tant chacun s'éloigne et part
dans son coin sur des thèses qui sont
des dérives qui sont autant de dérives
et dont on ne sortira pas alors nous
nous allons vivre cette bataille avec
le
espèce de de joie de s'engager de ceux
qui voient leurs idées désormais au
centre de la préoccupation générale donc
c'est une très grande chance
et on aura les les responsables des des
partis de la majorité mais il m'a semblé
que ça ne suffisait pas il m'a semblé
que pour cette discussion européenne
fallait qu'on qu'on qu'on bouleverse un
peu notre organisation pour qu'on puisse
parler avec les responsables eux-mêmes
et c'est la raison pour laquelle je vous
annonce que Thierry Breton commissaire
européen sera avec nous dimanche matin
pour parler de cette question centrale
de l'avenir de l'Europe je l'ai invité
il a accepté et ça sera un point de plus
de de de notre enracinement dans la
réflexion sur le sujet le plus important
de notre avenir nous avons beaucoup de
chance euh d'être là euh et comme tu le
disais euh tout à l'heure il y a 100 ans
que nous avons que nos prédécesseurs euh
dont un député des pyen Atlantique et
mon il y en avait même deux sur 14 ce
qui est pas si mal un député qui
s'appelit balanan aussi euh et il y
avait un il y avait un balanan aussi
mais il y avait un député un homme
formidable puisque à la
Libération lorsqu'on a cherché quelqu'un
d'irréprochable pour tous les
partis pour présider le premier Sénat on
disait le Conseil de la République à la
Libération on est allé chercher cet
homme de chez nous qui s'appelait
Auguste Champetier de RIB et dont la
salle du groupe centriste au Sénat porte
le nom depuis cette époque il était
quasiment mourant
il a été avec honneur le premier
président du Sénat capable de réunir
toutes les sensibilités de cette époque
donc on a fait ça je ne veux pas laisser
passer ce moment d'histoire pour les
plus jeunes d'entre nous sans rappeler
quelque chose qui doit faire notre
fierté de tous les
instants lorsque ont été
concéder pas négocier concéder les
accords de Munich
l'immense majorité des partis politiques
français ont approuvé applaudi ou se
sont
tu il n'y a un seul parti
politique qui a
choisi de prendre le risque incroyable
alors que toute l'opinion publique était
ovationné ceux qui avaient signé les
accords de munque un seul parti
politique c'est le parti démocrate
populaire de l'époque
petit
parti une dizaine de députés une
quinzaine de députés
et petit parti avec un petit journal
quotidien qui s'appelait
l'aube un beau nom de journal et dont
l'éditorial était signé par il avait 26
ou 27 ans un jeune agrégé d'histoire et
géographie qui aura un destin glorieux
et puis controversé après
glorieux parce que il aura été le
président du Conseil National de la
Résistance lorsque Jean Moulin a été
assassiné et
après il sera entraîné dans d'autres
visions et d'autres dérives à propos de
l'Algérie
française mais il a eu l'honneur de
signer l'éditorial avec une des phrases
les plus belles que j'ai rencontré de ma
vie et qui doit constamment nous servir
d'inspiration lorsqu'il s'agit de dire
non sa dernière phrase de l'Edito sur
Munich lorsqu'il s'agit de dire non le
meilleur moment c'est le premier et bien
rien que pour cette phrase et rien que
pour cette histoire de 100 années de
l'engagement national et européen qui
est le nôtre démocratique au travers de
la planète rien que pour cette certaine
idée de l'homme que nous portons je suis
très heureux que nous nous retrouvions à
Guidel merci à
tous